chair we're streaming live now thank you
thank you good morning and welcome to
the overview of scrutiny
one committee all participants are
taking part remotely
and we are live streaming to youtube
there will now be a role called
confirmation that members of the
committee are present
do the wrong call please trish thank you
thank you chair um cancer clarence
it's an apology councillor cox
that'll be me yeah present
yeah um cancer foden
presents cancer gribble
present council hocking
president councillor malone
president councillor natalie president
councillor patch president councillor
ollison
president councillor thorne president
um that's it joe i have apologies from
councillor jenks
councillor parker and councillor
clarence okay thank you very much
could you please make sure microphones
are muted when you're not speaking to
avoid any background noise levels
please keep your points short and do not
interrupt when someone is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic hand and wait to be called
when it comes to a vote if we are to
roll call
the democratic service officer will read
our members names
members please say if they're voting for
against or abstaining
alternatively the vote will be taken by
show of hands
we will look to make a break a
convenient time 90 minutes into the
meeting if required
if members lose internet connection the
meeting will be paused for a few minutes
to allow the members
to rejoin item one
i think we've already done that
apologies um
item two minutes of the last meeting
any comments on that please
um okay i'll propose to accept that if i
could have a second uh
thank you john john athlete
um could we do that on a hand show of
hands to
save time
thank you very much chair can you ask if
there's some any against or abstentions
please
any abstentions
thank you it's carried
item three any declarations of interest
i can't see any
and are there any public questions
no public questions chair and any
counsellor questions
no counselor questions chair thank you
thank you very much uh number
six executive forward plan
um just need to note that unless there's
any
comments on that anyone wants to say
anything
nope okay noted i think
item seven the work program again
to be noted are there any comments on
that
can't see any
okay that's fine um
item eight
there uh section member buy a new update
councillor wrigley homes and community
there will be time for questions
following the update should questions be
asked the counselor if he does not have
the information at hand to answer
responses will be provided by email or
via the members newsletter
counselor wrigley could i ask you to
give your update to the committee
thank you very much thank you chair
yes i've been told i have 15 minutes so
i'm hoping to
keep this brief um so apologies if i
don't go into the
a length of detail that you might be um
uh
expecting but happy to go into questions
afterwards
i sat down to prepare for this and i
thought hmm what we've been doing for
the last six months
and then i thought well we've got this
and we've got this and we've got this
and it turned into rather
a long long list so the very first thing
i have to say is thank you and thank you
to the team
uh who provide all of this the team of
officers
uh um led by amanda pujol and of course
including
graham davey tony mansour allison dooley
becca hewitt
tracy hooper and all of their teams they
um
have worked phenomenally hard through
all of the uh
the covid uh uh crisis they have
supported
all sorts of things going through and
and delivered a huge amount
on top of all of that
so sitting down it has been a really
useful exercise to sit down and look
back
and i'm blown away with how much we've
done
today you have on your agenda to
consider the
housing strategy so the new housing
strategy we've put together we've put
out
to consultation now normally on a
consultation of the housing strategy we
may get a hundred responses
this time we've got 500 responses
so we had a massively uh a good turnout
to the uh uh consultation in terms of
responding
and the response the the the answers
that people gave
were by and large pretty positive there
were some
questions in there which were mostly to
do with
planning issues and not housing strategy
issues
but an overwhelmingly positive response
for the housing strategy itself
i would be talking more about that later
on the agenda
and uh graham and um
uh um james are here to talk to that
we've had a review of the devon home
choice devon home choice is the system
that we run as i'm sure all councillors
know
to enable people to apply for
new housing this is run across
all of devon and it's run by a
management team that
includes all of the registered providers
all of the local authorities providing
homes
and there is a common set of policies
that allow people to uh to apply
and to have priority ranking for
um for allocation of new homes or new
housing requirements
it's an interesting one because we don't
have a full control of that because it
is common across devon
but we've gone through the home choice
review we've had that
uh approved by the executive we've
presented
to uh um a briefing to all of the
councillors
about devon home choice how it works
we've gone through and we've knocked on
the head some of the myths
about people from outside of devon
getting homes here
uh i in in preference it's clear
preference to local people
so that went through and went through
very well
we've had a huge uh drive
on the homelessness prevention and the
rough sleeper
initiatives this was helped initially by
the all-in
uh policies that were put into place
through covid
but even with that we have achieved uh
fantastic results um and we have
i've just lost my numbers
we have an annual target in terms of
homelessness prevention
which is assisting people to stay in
their own homes so that's
fixing issues that might cause them to
be otherwise homeless
our target of 160 households
we've actually achieved 276 so we've
nearly
nearly doubled that target and our other
target
which is clear is assisting clients into
alternative accommodation
in other words helping them find more
suitable housing from where they are
and if they didn't work that would also
result in homelessness
annual target there of some 267
and again we've blown away the annual
actual there and we've gone up to 309
so the team is working hard to make sure
that people are not
ending up homeless and when we see
people who are homeless on the street
that is clearly the tip of the iceberg
and the guys who are sleeping rough
guys and girls people who are sleeping
rough have also been helped
off the street as much as is possible
sometimes people find it difficult to
accept help
but by and large people are accepting
help and being
housed so that's been a very positive
thing
we've also been successful in uh bidding
for
funds to help support this initiative we
did a combined bid with south hams and
west devon councils for the rust sleep
rough sleeper initiative which is
basically a government-funded program
and we have a bid for some 231
000 pounds to secure staffing for that
uh to help accommodate rough sleepers
going forward
we will continue uh other bids as they
come up as funds become available there
are various initiatives coming out
from the mhclg the ministry of housing's
communities local government
and that will help us add to our list of
properties where we can help people uh
into homes where they would other
otherwise be homeless
we tend to use um individual housing as
opposed to big hostels
because we find it works better than
trying to put everybody into big sort of
uh
big hostels which is what some other
authorities do
um i could talk all day on the
homelessness
things but like i said i have only 15
minutes
we have a a lot of work going on with
heating grants
this is where we take grants for heating
we have warm homes funding which is
helping us
install 100 homes with
air source heat pumps we have
successfully
bid for a chunk of money 1.1 million
pounds from the local authority delivery
green
green homes grants
this is the part of the green homes
[Music]
grant funding that was announced by
government that went through local
authority
the consumer version has now been pulled
but this is continuing
that will provide another households
with
another 100 households with air source
heat pumps
and these are aimed at people who are
living in fuel poverty
the air source heat pump is considerably
cheaper
to run and obviously has a significant
impact
on improving decreasing
our carbon footprint across the district
we have other programs that are still
going on obviously the same team is
looking after also
disabled facilities grants helping
people
adapt their homes to help them stay in
their homes if they need
uh wheelchair access on on steps for
example you see homes with
with ramps fitted outside and other
adaptations that are less
obvious to the outside we also have a
program supporting park homes
putting efficient heating into the park
homes which
tend to be poorly isolated insulated
um and this is is
going well it's a difficult one because
this is one that is
is going against some of the things that
that we would like to see because it's
installing gas boilers
but it is the um it is a condition of
that funding um
it's replacing uh the worse
lpg heaters that are not only
inefficient but also
have as i understand it a worse carbon
footprint anyway
that will be phasing out in the not too
distant future
community safety comes under the the
portfolio as well
uh we have a new anti-social behavior
officer who has been
appointed and is in post and working
we have been working on the new phases
of turning corners that
is the youth uh intervention scheme
that has been ex recognized as extremely
helpful
across the whole of the community safety
partnership and that has new funding
that will take it forward
and you will have seen also implemented
has been the public space protection
order in
tinmuth which has uh which is helping
the police to crack down on problems
caused by
outdoor drinking in the areas around the
den
in tinmouth
slightly less positive is
the members itesu iron strata
this is the uh changing the provision
that we have
for some away from the all-in-one
ipad which is uh eminently suitable for
some people
not suitable for some who have more
complex or sophisticated i.t
requirements
and uh we did talk about an office 365
rollout commencing in
april i'm pushing for a better date but
strata are currently talking about that
for the middle of the summer
what we are looking to do and i would
like to invite
uh councillors on this committee to
think about joining
is getting a handful of councillors to
form a counsellor's user group for it
in other words trying to get a cross
section
of counsellors and their needs for it so
that we can
correctly identify to strata what people
need
rather than assuming one size fits all
for everybody
or rather an issue rather than assuming
that strata know what counsellors need
it's become clear that they really don't
understand how we
use the i.t and what we need
to do our jobs
which brings us on to um i'll come on to
the section 106 housing delivery in a
moment
i'd just like to say a brief word about
customer services customer services
have taken the brunt of a lot of the
extra work
in um the time of kovid
and and they have stood up fantastically
tracy hooper and her team have been the
front of all of the
grants the business grants the phone
calls helping people
sorting out people's issues doing all of
the extra work
for the public that the council has been
doing and they have performed superbly
and i take my hat off to them
and cannot praise them highly enough
which brings me onto the last thing i
want to
talk about which is probably the largest
section of the
of the uh portfolio which is housing
uh housing has been is always a
a an interesting thing we have
in the early stage of this year we had a
very very low delivery of
affordable houses i think q1 this year
was the first time ever when we
delivered
none this was purely because in the
early lockdowns
the housing
development just stopped since then it
has
picked up and gone forward a pace
and we have been delivering through the
section 106
we have now delivered 121 new homes
new affordable homes across the district
just for clarity this is uh largely
through
uh developers
building homes and
selling them to registered providers
registered providers
bid for the affordable homes that are
included in any of the new larger
developments
and they all bid against each other and
the developers will choose out of those
bids which one they wish to go
forward with those homes then become the
property of the registered providers
and they then use devon home choice to
find
the residents to to take up those new
homes
so all ties together the other way we
get new affordable homes
is when registered providers themselves
build new homes that does happen
but about i think it's about 80 percent
of
affordable homes that are delivered are
delivered through the
main main developers at the moment
in terms of delivery of new homes the
other thing that we have now
going forward is the team bridge 100
and i can happily show you that the team
bridge 100 is commencing a pace
these are the two new homes the first
two up in
uh drake road in newton abbott
two new uh
houses for uh affordable rent when they
are finished
and if i remember correctly they're due
to be finished and ready for occupation
this summer they have been
built to a very high standard
of energy efficiency of uh
everything that we can possibly do to
reduce the co2 footprint
you will note on the roofs there the
photovoltaic solar panels
so they're fully fitted with solar
panels they'll have
electric car car charging points
high degree of insulation every uh
local option that we can possibly take
they're being built
not by a big national developer
they're being built by a local firm
here in the area so it's providing local
employment
as well as building everything in um
in in to as higher standard as we
possibly
can um
sorry about the the patch on the screen
at the moment that will go away
there perfect uh there is more
information on the
major projects page on the website if
anyone wants to look into that to see
what is being provided with
these new homes the other ones
uh immediately underway are in east
street this is a block of five flats
on ground that was previously a car park
there has been no way that these could
otherwise be developed
other than through the authority
developing these
um and we are doing this in a way
where we are taking advantage of all the
grant support that we can
to deliver not only an asset to this
council
but additional new homes but also
something that is uh it washes its face
in financial terms
so through the way that this has been
built
it will not in the end cost a penny
it will make a small return and we will
have the asset
at the end of the day and we'll provide
homes for people locally
and jobs for people locally so the way i
see it it's a win-win-win
if i missed anything on the standards we
have
air source heat pumps in these in these
buildings we have solar
pv electric car charging points
mechanical heat recovery and ventilation
system and an
a-rating thermal efficiency
and both of these sites are bringing
brownfield
redundant sites back into use
to provide homes for people locally
i think i've probably taken my time
unless there's anything that i've
forgotten
let me just check my list um
one other thing to add that we've also
within this last period
run the community hardship grants
where we have distributed 30 000 pounds
through from devon to local projects
that have bid
targeting loneliness and digital
exclusion
and improving mental health and we
obviously have been
the team has been uh working
with the uh devon across devon teams
in the covid recovery programs and they
have been very active
in in leading some of those so it has
been a busy six months
within all these areas i think a lot has
been achieved
and i think it's all positive and i i
asked the committee to to ask any
questions that they'd like
thank you very much council of wrigley
any questions
for councillor wrigley
look john
nothing please thank you joe yeah
thank you for that martin uh very very
positive
all round i think um obviously regards
the homeless and rough sleepers
um it seems good news on that but what
the actual
figures you know compared to what they
used to be and what do they compare to
at the moment
um i don't have those figures on me we
did have
i did have some for the end of march
which what we're trying to do
is get the housing numbers the people
who re
who who find new homes uh published in
the members newsletter on a district
award-by-ward basis in the future
i will find the numbers for the current
rough sleepers
[Music]
after the meeting and and circulate them
and put them in the members newsletter
as well
okay thank you
yeah yeah yeah um obviously with the
affordable homes etc
um i know it comes under dartmouth
national park on the planning side of
things
um but in ashburton um excellent news at
longson cross where we've actually got
39 affordable social houses being built
and they've actually
a good start on those now um that will
be going forward for i know it comes
within the team bridge uh
district but uh i say that will be for
obviously local people but
uh you know it's fantastic as obviously
with ashburton there's not many areas
where we can actually find uh to be able
to build uh
build these properties i know the the
plot of ground that uh
was involved there was uh um belonged to
devon county um and a private
owner um and at one time it was here in
march for a primary school but uh
i say i think that's no not required and
i say it's great news that we've got
these hoses going up but uh
yeah just uh just a point making on that
one thank you thank you council yes that
is excellent news and there's a number
of other
programs like the new bungalows in
denbury and there's a range of
uh programs that we are working with
individual communities to bring
forward uh small developments in in
different places where
where they can be done involving
community land trusts
and involving the local community to
bring those forward they take a lot of
time and cajoling to bring into into
fruition but they're certainly well
worth it when they happen
don't seem to have any more questions
there um
i see mike hocking and adrian patch with
their hands up okay
sorry my thing isn't working very well
uh
council hocking please
yeah thank you uh chairman um mine's
just a
hopefully a quick question um we have
the land at
um in newton uh bradley lane
we have the industrial state now um and
there is a plan for i believe 170
um social housing stroke affordable
housing
um which is good good news um my
my question is there we have other areas
um within the town which have industrial
estates
which don't necessarily fit within the
town center
um is there is there any
option to actually move these industrial
states
to the outskirts of the town and i'm
thinking of the main area which would
probably be
around silver and actually using that
land
that they vacate as brownfield land
it'll be cheaper for the council to buy
obviously uh and um cheaper therefore
cheaper to be able to build
um affordable housing and subsidizing
because at the end of the day it is it
is
um cheap rented
uh a social housing that a lot of the
low paid workers that live within
newton abbot think muftalish um within
the area
actually need um so do you think it's
time that
we started thinking outside of the box a
little bit
um and instead of putting industrial
units and that within a town
center let's move them out and actually
use
the land naval cape as as um
land that can that no is bromfield and
can now be used
a much cheaper as a cheaper option thank
you councillor
yes that that sort of principle is
certainly some of the areas that we're
looking at in the team bridge 100
program and i would like to see us look
at
more areas where that can be done having
said that
there is a fine balance between having
appropriate
local areas where people can walk to
work
compared with having to drive to the
outside of town to an industrial estate
so there are some times where it's
beneficial to keep that but there will
be some that may be
financially viable to do that one of the
difficulties with changing such a site
is that if you turn up to a company and
says right you're going to have to move
then we end up having to help them move
and it costs a
significant amount of money and
disruption to move
companies that are of significant size
but if there are opportunities where we
can make the
logistics the money the sums the the
balance between
uh walking to work and and having to
drive to somewhere out of town
and have places that would be better off
as homes rather than industrial areas
absolutely we should certainly should be
looking at those yes
and if you have such areas we'd be happy
to i'd personally be happy to uh
to go around with you and see if we can
find them and find a way to include them
in the programme for the team bridge 100
yep thank you for that uh councillor
patch please
well thank you chair um thank you
councillor wrigley for an interesting
presentation as well
um in uh my ward we've recently had
questionnaires going out for a housing
needs survey
and i'm sure we're not alone in that
these exercises take place across the
district
i just wondered um if anyone
including yourself um has a look at
these um
survey results in aggregate uh across
the district
in terms of the paints the picture is
painted about
the local housing need across the
district and obviously there
i'd have an interest in the extent to
which that then feeds into local plan
development um planning policy and
planning decisions
um i just wonder if that's an issue
that's on your radar really
aggregates local housing need local
housing needed certainly on my radar as
soon as you start talking about
uh local plan process that's outside of
my
my remit but obviously i have an
interest
to me the most pressing thing is that we
have
a thousand households on our housing
needs register within the district
every year we house about 400 of them
and every year it's slightly more on the
list than it was at the beginning of the
year
so we need to find affordable housing
across the area
that we can bring forward and we can
deliver and that's why i think the team
bridge 100
which adds to the social housing that is
being delivered
is so important to do that and i'm
looking forward to that bringing that
to that bringing the numbers down
affordable housing
is my focus and where we can find it and
when we can find it on brownfields i'm
much much happier
okay thank you
okay i think that's it i've just one
question myself
about homelessness
so there's various figures i think
they'll be coming up in the next section
but
there's obviously a big hidden amount of
homelessness
is there any how are we addressing that
because for instance rough sleepers you
can
you know how many roughly there are but
there are an awful lot of people that
are
technically haven't got a home but they
may be sleeping in someone's city or
whatever
is is there any way of measuring that
well
there is in a way thank you chair that
that's an excellent uh an excellent
point
there is when we talk about homelessness
rough sleeping is just the the tip of
the iceberg that is when
people have have got to a a point where
they literally have nowhere else to go
um and that is that is a a
personal and and
a personal crisis for them and a crisis
across society you know we should not be
in a position
in 2021 where people are sleeping in the
street that really should not be there
but you're absolutely right there are
large numbers of people
who are who are hidden who don't have a
permanent home
who don't have a place they can call
home who
are sleeping on a friend's sofa who are
uh uh um not not
apparent it's difficult to measure
the absolute numbers there because you
know for every
uh um grown-up uh um young family
still living with their parents and
bursting at the seams of the the small
house their parents are in
we we can't tell we can't find those we
do
know some of the statistics that i was
mentioning earlier about the people we
have helped into
uh preventing them to become homeless
the people we have helped to sort of
move and find better accommodation but
in
absolute terms do we know how many
people are sleeping on somebody else's
couch
no if they're not registered you know
the house
the house is registered with council tax
the people may be registered on the
electoral roll
we could do some work with that but
people who are moving from sofa to sofa
tend not to appear on any of these
things we don't really know
unless we go out and do surveys and ask
and even then
they probably wouldn't tell us so
through the work that the team do
we find a good number of people through
the outreach teams
but in terms of an absolute number no an
indication from what we can achieve and
what we're already doing
yes sorry so it's it's a partial answer
to your question really though
yeah that's that's fine it's just um i'm
very aware there are a lot of
people who aren't yeah haven't got home
and such
and it's pretty much impossible to
get a number on that but i think when
you're looking at
housing needs there's probably a lot
more hidden
than we actually think there is um
so the actual housing needs a lot more
than they
officially are that makes any sense i
think so
and there is sort of survey that
councillor patch was referring to might
help us
but the thing that will help us most of
all
and we're very fortunate is the national
um uh census that just went through
and so long as we get uh truthful
responses across the area for that
declaring all the people who are in each
house
at the time that will give us a snapshot
picture
for the reality of people who are who
are in
uh um difficult situations like that
where there are too many people
living in a in a house where people are
effectively homeless
thank you very much um
got no more questions thanks very much
for the presentation
um i think that's it yep moving on to
item nine which i believe
martin you're going to do a quick
introduction
yes just just just very very very
briefly so
um i think uh um the officers will do
more details on this so the housing
strategy is reviewed
uh periodically um and we look into
all sorts of areas this not only covers
the work that we're looking at in terms
of
team bridge 100 and provision of extra
affordable
homes it covers the work that we do in
terms of
helping private landlords
ensure that their properties are up to
scratch
so there's a lot of things in here
beyond
uh the immediate we will deliver however
many houses through
section 106 through new build it goes
into
a lot of detail in a lot of areas one of
the things that we put into this
is a good number of graphs
that show how the numbers have changed
over time because
to me it's not about a snapshot it's
about a strategy it's about are the
numbers going in the right direction
is this council doing all the things
that it possibly can
to ensure that uh people have
secure and adequate housing for their
needs
do they have a place that they can call
home and do they have a
a secure place where they can build
lives from
and that's a fundamental duty of this
council that we should be doing
and not just counting the numbers of new
houses built
and this strategy shows how we go about
doing that
and shows what we're trying to achieve
in terms of doing that
um i'd like to hand over to to more
detail
uh graham is it yourself or is it um
to to graham uh uh our housing inv
in a housing enablement and housing
enabling and development
officer to give you some more detail if
i may thank you
thank you martin and good morning
members um martin obviously has
introduced the paper and i will just um
add a little bit more meat onto the bone
if
if that's appropriate and then obviously
we will open the debate for
for questions um as martin alluded to
we have a current housing strategy that
has run for a five-year period
and that um that that strategy has
expired in in april of this year hence
the reason for
a new strategy to replace it
obviously if we're having a housing
strategy it needs to be fit for purpose
in terms of providing that overall
framework
against which the council can formulate
other more specific
policies and to to deliver its its
housing objectives
with regards to the document itself and
and where does it sort of sit in the
council's hierarchy
well obviously the housing strategy sits
beneath the council strategy
and the local plan but it is overarching
which covers the other strategies which
sit below that
which is the homelessness and rust
sleeping strategy the tenancy strategy
the empty homes policy etc etc and i
think you'll see in the forward plan
that uh
the empty homes policy is one of the
next policies to to come before overview
and screw
me at um at the next round of meetings
housing obviously is a is an extremely
high priority
for the local authority always has been
and i'm sure always will be
and the actions that have that that have
come out of the the current housing
strategy
are reported in spa and those spa
reports come quarterly to yourselves
um through the overview and scrutiny
committee via via martin wrigley
um and that process will continue so
there's the strategy that is that has
been drafted at the moment that's before
you today
is really split into uh five main themes
that
reflect as martin has said the work that
we do
starting with building affordable homes
and getting back into our own
development programme
improving existing homes primarily in
the private sector
preventing homelessness and addressing
rust sleeping which we've already had
questions about today
ensuring um from our point of view and
from a staff point of view which is
which is important is about putting the
client first
and equally as importantly about
tackling climate change so those are the
five
broad themes of the strategy
uh moving on from a financial
perspective
obviously some of the uh the budgets
have been alluded to
um they are already in the budget report
that was approved by full council in
february
um supporting the administration's
priority of housing jobs and climate
change
um and that budget obviously includes
work on
funding for disabled facilities grants
starting the early parts of our housing
delivery
and funding for our new initiative of
the shared equity scheme
so the strategy itself and the
consultation which we did
whether it's because we did all of our
consultation online this this time or or
the world that we're currently in but
yeah we have had a six-fold increase in
the number of comments that we've had
back on the strategy this time round
the consultation ran from 17th to feb to
the 24th of march
and we did have over 500 responses and
the report
actually lists out all of the um the
organizations and groups that
uh that that consultation went out to
and that includes members towns and
parish councils and
we've had a broad spectrum of feedback
which was really encouraging
um some just completed the questions
that were on the
the questionnaire but 300 of those took
the time to put additional comments back
in
in their responses which is which is
really encouraging
um not surprisingly about 62 percent of
the responses did relate
specifically to to planning policy we
have collated
all of those comments that have come
back and any of those comments that have
gone to
uh that relate to specific policies like
public open space like um
planning etc etc all of those comments
have gone on to the appropriate offices
and those appropriate departments and
they will deal with those points
accordingly
and obviously planning will have the
opportunity to to feed those comments
into
the work when they go out and consult on
the on the next stage of
the local plan the online survey did
show
a strong endorsement of the five themes
of our strategy
which was really encouraging and then of
those five themes
narrowly building more affordable homes
came out as a top priority but strongly
followed by
tackling climate change addressing
homelessness and improving
existing homes i won't go through all of
the breakdown on the table which you've
got before you about the areas of which
those responses came back but
clearly we have put some further text
within the report
but a lot of that actually is sort of
areas that you've already touched on in
the comments that we've made and the
comments that came back from the public
um it's about where possible not using
not not using green fields
encouraging us to to use brownfield land
wherever possible
and that we will do ensuring that where
new housing and that's affordable
housing as well is delivered that
there are the infrastructures to support
that affordability
was something that very strongly came
back and that's why we've got a desire
that certainly from the the new homes
that
uh that martin discussed earlier on at
drake road and e street that are under
uh that are under construction
um they are being um built and will be
completed to
to the cheapest possible rents to social
rents not affordable rents making them
as affordable as possible to the
lucky residents that will be moving into
them um
brownfield land obviously was something
that
we're encouraged to use coming back
through the responses and making use of
empty homes which feeds in quite well to
as i said the report that will be coming
forward in due course on our empty homes
policy
design was something that was important
as well and good design and i think
martin's alluded to that when discussing
about drake road and e street
um the the amount of effort that we've
put into into good design into into
those properties
um and again there was feedback with
regards to the allocation of of new
affordable housing ensuring that we do
spread our delivery not only just in the
in the urban areas of newton albert and
timothy dawlish that uh
we have got a spread of schemes across
the district
um as councillor nutley has referred to
within the dartmoor national park as
well
um he alluded to the scheme at ashburton
which is really encouraging to see that
coming out of the ground
but also we've had a recent planning
consent that's been granted for 100
affordable housing scheme that would
come in the more
um you know what one would think is sort
of not the middle of nowhere but
a community that that needs support um
and obviously that
and those schemes have been backed by
rural housing needs surveys which again
was alluded to earlier
so the report then just goes on to cover
the the areas the amendments that we
have made
i'm pleased to say we haven't had to
make too many amendments to the strategy
um because we have had a very good
endorsement of what went out there and
um
it's good that we've had wide
consultation and i just really would
want to conclude in the
what it just just literally say in the
conclusion the council is proud of its
history of providing affordable housing
improving housing conditions and
tackling homelessness
and we certainly hope that this refresh
strategy describes how the council will
continue
um to expand our innovative approach um
to deliver solutions to meet the
the needs of the whole of our community
um there's nothing
further that i wish to stay at this
stage but i'm sure the chair will run
through any questions that people have
anything affordable housing related team
bridge 100 i will
try and uh respond as best as i can
the details that are in the report james
toda the author of that report is here
if there are any specific questions
about the
the data that went in the report um and
amanda pushall is on the uh
on the line as well who can cover any
questions with regards to private sector
housing and homelessness
so thank you thank you very much
um any questions please
john nutley please there's nowhere else
to put the rounds up
on this one on 2.1 um where it's
mentioned about brexit
um i know obviously there is
difficulties and reading through this
report here
difficulties with materials and that uh
coming forward um obviously not being
able to come into the country etc
i don't know what uh whether you've got
any updates on on that side of things
and we know the the stamp duty will be
coming to an end
um on the homes etc which is
a shame for obviously new new people
building
um but as i say i'm just wondering
what the fact no it's having you know
brexit side of things whether that's
having
an ongoing effect on materials etc for
that
[Music]
that chair are you happy for me to
respond
yeah that's fine thank you um one of the
things that we do do regularly is meet
with all of our housing association
partners and we held our last meeting
six eight weeks ago and i think
councillor wrigley was was at that
meeting
one of the things that we do is go
around the table with all of our
partners to
um get back from them the the latest
intelligence from the market
um i mean obviously when the the
strategy started drafting a little while
ago and obviously we had to sort of
state what the national context is
um but actually from that roundtable
discussion and feedback that we had from
our partners who worked
closely with with uh with a range of
developers um it was all very positive
the sounds that were coming back and
that
locally there aren't any specific issues
with regards to shortage of materials or
labor
um and all of the partners were
reporting the fact that um
it was as west as best as can be
business as usual i think that's
probably reflected in
martin wrigley's earlier comments about
our affordable housing delivery whereby
um we started from a point in the first
quarter of the financial year
um first time ever our affordable
delivery was nil
when we're looking at a target for the
year of 128 and we've managed to claw
that back to 121 it does show that uh
that the market is is moving forward
quite quite quickly
um and actually um as will appear in the
spa reports coming forward our
projections for
next or the current financial year for
affordable housing delivery
um are looking very very positive so i'm
pleased to say that uh
it hasn't had the um the the sort of the
doomsdays and gleamsters um
views coming forward actually thank you
very much
uh mike cochin please
yeah thank you uh chairman um just a
couple of little things really um
reading the report is
quite obvious the amount of work that
cambridge has done over the
over the years and the amount of work
that probably a lot of us don't realize
that that's being done
so we we have to we have to take our hat
off
for that respect for the work that's
been done um
back in the um back in the sort of
late 90s when uh when tingbridge
passed all their housing stock over to
housing authorities because
we were led to believe that that was the
right right way to go
um governments let us that led us that
way
it was obvious that tingbridge couldn't
borrow money to um to repair houses like
a housing authority could
and then there was also we had also the
the rights to buy which
i totally agree with but the monies that
was coming in from that
wasn't allowed to be spent on re
replenishing the stock
um so we we're in the situation where we
are and
um because of what's happened in the
past now
um when you look at them and you've
mentioned design
when you look at the new housing houses
that's going on around and newt nava has
had
more than its fair share of houses
that's being built
um obviously 20 of them are supposed to
be
um low cost or social housing when you'd
actually look at the design of them
let's be fair they stick out like a sore
thumb
when you start looking at the rest of
the the buildings around which
are which are being privately bought and
privately owned
um i think that we should be doing more
to encourage the developer
i know it's a cheap way of their of them
doing what they want to do
but we should be encouraging them to
actually blend the houses in a book
a lot better than what they're doing um
within the estates that they're building
and i'll say and if i go on then to my
next question
is um the right to buy and others
say although i can understand i
understand it and
don't disagree with what uh the
sentiment behind it
because everybody should have the right
to buy their own home the money that's
being put
back or money that's being um brought
back from that
is that now being allowed to go back
into so we can go back into our stocks
so we can continue to build these um
so these you know most needed houses uh
council wrigley said earlier on that um
we have a thousand uh people on our
waiting list every year and
that we get we've managed to sort of
sort 400
but each year that thousand tends to
grow
so you know there is there is and
there is an urgency here that we should
be we should be doing a lot more
and i and i quite believe that the
thing bridge 100 is is a way forward
but is it just too little too late and
shouldn't we actually be trying to do
a lot more than what we're doing um even
if we
turn around and like this will obviously
be a planning thing to actually increase
the number of social housing that
these developers are made to build
you know um let's let's hold them to
court
why should they be making 20 profit on
on an estate
when actually we're struggling to make
sure that people who live in this
this area have got a i've got a home of
their own
that's my two questions thank you thank
you council hawking
um i've got martin wrigley there
or if it's all right i'd just like to
respond to a couple of those
um those comments uh and thank
thank councillor hawking for uh for
those questions
um you're right there are a lot of
things
in national planning law that tie
our hands and there is not a huge amount
that we can do
about it in terms of
the right to buy from the stock that
team bridge sold a number of years ago
certainly before my time
that has uh given us a trickle of income
but that is now coming to an end
because the time has run out so when
we're not going to see
anything in terms of the right to buy
monies coming in we are constrained by
what we can do
by government in in terms of so many of
these areas
and by what we can legally put into the
local plans
in terms of restrictions and in terms of
uh the numbers that we are demanding we
always
ask for as many affordable
homes in the developments as we can
possibly um
uh hope for um and we will often be
argued down by developers in terms
of um uh
um viability uh
and they will then go to the government
over our heads and say
we're allowed to do this and we're
allowed to do that and and we are
constrained with what we can do the
concept of of of pepper potting putting
the
affordable homes so that they can't be
identified or
aren't obviously standing out amongst
the developments is already there and
should be
um is encouraged um
but in terms of building a faster rate
of team bridge 100
i would love to say yes we'll put in a
thousand tomorrow because that's what we
need we'll have a thousand households
but that would be foolish i think i
think to sort of jump
immediately over such a large hurdle
whilst we're out of
the habit of building and delivering
so the idea of the team bridge 100 is
that we're starting
slow making sure that we get it right
learning through the process and
accelerating as we go on
so it's a pipeline of 100 homes that we
can develop and bring forward
a pipeline that we will keep fulfilled
and i'm hoping that our delivery
rate for these homes will increase
and increase over time as we prove
that we can deliver them we deliver them
well
and we deliver them effectively and cost
effectively
for the council so yeah fully endorse
all of your uh all of your
all of your feelings and i think yeah we
we need to start and we're making a
start
and we've got to start somewhere and
we're not trying to do a massive big
project
that has a big failure possibility
starting slow getting going walking
before we can run
but i want us to be running and
delivering these homes as we go forward
thank you jeremy
yes yeah thank you for that
uh um although i understand exactly what
you're saying about
um pepper potting the the um
social housing low cost housing in an
estate
that is not though it is they're being
put in different areas
agreed they have still not been designed
as the as the private houses houses are
they still stand out you can drive
through any estate
um in in ting bridge and you will be
able to pick out i
swear you'll be able to pick out the the
social housing
and the low cost housing the one at hill
park
um on the round that they put a new
roundabout in right on the roundabout
you have two huge um blocks of flats
now if that isn't standing out and
telling and telling you something
then what is i think we need to we
really need to sort of hit these
developers
we've met so make sure that they put in
um properly designed properties that
don't stand out does it make a you know
why should i go into a rented
accommodation when i'm there
it stands out and says look you're in a
rented accommodation
maybe down the road driving in movies
with his large vehicle
is in a private house and it stands out
that it's a private house
we need to get this we need to get these
these um designs
correct and i don't think we're doing
that and it may be down to put
down to national policies and and the
power of these um
these developers they have over us but
surely to make sure that we're an
integrated
society then we all should be looking as
though we're living in
a similar sort of um accommodation
thank you mike um any comments
just just if if i'm here yeah
indeed counselor and uh this is why we
have the strategies in the local plan
and that's i think where that that needs
to be it's it's a planning issue rather
than a housing issue
thank you martin uh councillor patch
please
thank you chair um yeah i'd just like to
follow up some of the
very very good points that councillor
hawkins made about um
the affordable housing and rented um
social housing how it stands out
i think it's not just a case of
aesthetics
um we're as a nation and
um as members becoming increasingly
aware
particularly with regard to planning
issues the threats that um
poor air quality and pollution play in
terms of health
and um as this as this knowledge builds
up i i think that um
as another sort of um sort of raft of
questions about the positioning
of the affordable social social housing
right up against busy main roads um
as has been sort of pointed out with in
particular with regard to one
development
i don't think that development is is a
is a standout example
um i i'd just like to sort of put that
into the mix of something that um
ought to be considered if um
team bridge is to take seriously the
issues that council hawking's raised
thank you councillor patch um
so can i just make a comment on that
certainly uh thank you councillor again
this is a planning issue run the housing
issue and i urge you to put your input
into the uh
local plan uh uh strategy um policies
that are being put together
thank you um any more questions
yet can't see any
um i've got a couple myself
um something that's been brought to my
attention in my area is
and i think it was in the report as well
of
private rented landlords selling up
or getting out the business which is um
[Music]
pushing up the amount of people that
need rented accommodation
and also people moving into the area
pushing the prices up
which is gonna push up the need for
rented accommodation
little people i've been speaking to are
looking to get
social rented because there isn't enough
private rented at the moment
which is gonna increase demand for
social rented
but i think there's some confusion
between
affordable housing and social housing
and sometimes
there's
there seems to me to be more of a more
of a demand for
rented accommodation than to buy
affordable if that's so just
if there's any comments on that please
martin thank you chair yes uh these are
trends that we are
keeping an eye on that there's a limited
amount of things that we can do about it
but when you look at the
uh um i'll try to remember from i think
it's
the average house price is 11 times the
median salary of the area if i remember
rightly
um and and that is just brings the whole
definition of affordable
into it's just unreal
so we are in a situation where the
housing market is fundamentally broken
in the country
there are trends that are being done the
government is making changes
they're not all helping the situation
um you're right we're seeing a trend of
people
selling up as as various sort of tax
breaks that were put into place are
removed
and various other uh financial changes
in terms of buy to let and all the rest
of it
we can only monitor the situation and
and respond
in in as fast as we can in terms of
encouraging the registered providers to
provide more homes
in terms of encouraging the developers
to provide more section 106 homes for
the registered providers
and pushing ahead with team bridge 100
we help private landlords we have a
program
of um uh uh supporting them to be good
landlords
and we have a registered uh um
i cannot remember the name of it the
r-a-r-a-p-a-s
the registers private landlord scheme i
think
um i apologize for misremembering the uh
um
the term of it to do what we can to help
private landlords
but if they are selling up and there is
a reduction in in rented property
we just need to step up the pace of
delivery
thank you for that um i've got
one more question
it's about the holiday home business
rates
um so
there's a bit of a loophole that if you
have a holiday home
you can register it as a business and
end up not paying any rates at all
i know it's in certain areas it's quite
a big problem and
probably not such a problem in team
bridge but i know
where i live on the walls there are a
lot of holiday homes
i was wondering were there any figures
on that
or any information
graham boost
apologies just trying to unmute um i i
did wonder if it was a question that was
that was going to be raised and i did
take the liberty of talking to tracy
hooper who heads up the um the council
tax department this morning
um she did say to me and i i know what
the um that the point you're alluding to
whether you describe it as a as a
loophole i mean
it's nothing that's being done that it
that is illegal but any ways to change
it
does rely on government policy to amend
that it's nothing that is within the
gift of team british district councils
change policies
um in the way that people potentially
class second homes as
as businesses um but um it is something
that um the
the staff involved are fully aware of um
if you needed some further clarification
then i think
um tracy hooper would be the appropriate
officer to to talk to
um but i did mention it to her i think
it's something that the leader has
raised with her as well
um but it does rely on um it does rely
on national policy
to make any changes it's not something
within the gift of team bridge or any
other local authority
the likes of obviously south hams and
west um west evan that have
a much larger number of second homes
than we do in team bridge
thank you very much for that um
right no no more questions on that
um thank you very much for all the work
on this report it's pretty good stuff
i'd like to propose that we accept this
um could i have a seconder on that
please
thank you councillor foden i think you
need to go
to roll call on that one please trish
yes thank you chair um
councillor foden
councillor gribble
agreed i'm sorry with dogs i'm going
bananas
cancer hocking yeah
counsellor malone
sorry um i'll abstain thank you
councillor nutley or counselor patch
or counselor rollerson or
councillor thorne or and yourself chair
that's carried there's eight eight
votes for and one abstention thank you
very much
um item 10 pspo control of dogs task and
finish group um
do we is david eats i'm gonna speak to
this or is
we just need to
chair i hadn't planned to speak to this
um okay but
i'm happy to if you if you'd like me to
i think i'll just go for
everyone should have read it um if there
are any questions on that please
uh councillor foden
thank you chair could i just ask i've
been interested in reading this
um this report um could i just ask
it mentions about the online survey
um when when that is likely to happen
will that be
this this spring this summer and
the reason i ask is that i know
where i live in dallas there's a lot of
interest in
um dog issues and um
um sort of instructions or
um recommendations about dogs on leads
and because there's been a another
attack on one of the signets
by a dog this weekend and i was just
wondering about the
online survey because i know a lot of
residents here in dallas will be very
interested in giving their views
um and the other question that i have is
um i'm i really i really approve of
what's mentioned in this report will
there be any
um recommendations for enforcement
through dog wardens um
that's my question thank you
chair would you like me to answer those
hold on sorry i got distracted yes
please if you wouldn't mind
okay so in answer to councillor photons
question
um the date for any survey work
has not been determined the first time
the proposed task finish group will meet
is the 10th of may
that will be one of the first key points
for the group to consider
how they propose to consult with town
and parish councils and through
yourselves and the public so that will
be uh considered in
that first meeting with regard to your
second question
um the recommendations i don't want to
pre-determine what the recommendations
of the task and finish group
were but if you wanted to make some
observations um
through to the group once it's formed
feel free to and if that's related to
enforcement you know the group
can consider that thank you very much
thank you so
[Music]
we need to do sure excuse me chad um
councillor
thank you thank you very much chair
sorry my fingers weren't going fast
enough to raise my blue hand and i was
frantically waving
um yeah i just wanted to to add to uh
what
david has said and to say that our
enforcement officers
are out there as we speak and
if they find uh infringements
things like dog attacks um are on
on the on the the birds uh and swans at
dawlish anything of that sort of nature
uh they will come down
on on people who who don't have their
dogs on a lead in a place where they
should have uh
and and they will levy fines um so so
people should be aware and there's been
a lot of publicity about
about this type of thing we are rolling
out uh signs
as well that uh our environmental
wardens
uh can use um to to to to
get the message over that in places like
that
people should keep their dogs on a lead
and they also should be picking up after
them
if they foul and uh and and
this council will not tolerate uh people
who abuse that kind of thing
particularly in a place like dawlish
which is a family
uh a wonderful family resort and the
thought
uh that that dogs could be attacking um
the the the swans and the light is just
horrible
so uh yeah uh councillor foden you you
have my assurance that we'll be there
and and looking after uh that
thanks chair thank you very much
councillor judas
so we need to agree to the terms of
reference i'll take it everyone's read
them
um i'd like to propose that we do
could i have a second for that thank you
councillor nutley
uh could we do a roll call on that
please
trish yes chair thank you
um councillor foden
councillor gribble or
councillor hawking
councillor malone four
councillor natalie or councillor patch
or councillor wallacen or
councillor thorne and yourself chair
okay that's unanimous chairs carrie
thank you very much
and finally item 10 strata
joint executive minutes on the 20th
january 2021
um any questions on that i'm sure you've
read or
read through them
have you sorry allister you've still got
your hand up for
the last thing yeah okay
uh apologies no problem um
okay so we just need to note that um
you're located on a show of hands i
think
great thank you very much chair there
any chairs yeah or abstentions
i don't think so no all good
that's carried by majority thank you
chair thank you very much
right that's the end of this meeting
thank you very much for your time
and uh see you at the next one bye now